en ce moment il se passe beaucoup de
choses avec la pandémie et tout votre
très vite le virus le vaccin la
recherche ça peut être très difficile de
s'y retrouver
vous avez beaucoup de questions et au
cours des prochaines semaines on va
tenter d'y répondre le plus clairement
possible parce que c'est très important
que vous soyez et formés sur ce qui se
passe si vous avez des questions
n'hésitez pas à nous les envoyer à
l'adresse que vous voyez au bas de
l'écran on en a déjà reçu plusieurs on
va commencer tout de suite avec la
première
[Musique]
la réponse courte c'est non on peut
répondre de deux façons la première
c'est qu'il ya pas de vaccin moderne qui
contient un virus assez en forme pour
nous faire attraper la maladie
le vaccin conventionnelle utilisent les
virus de trois façons d'abord soit c'est
un virus inactivé on peut dire mort soit
scellé vraiment de virus donc encore
plus mort soit ce sont des virus
affaibli donc des virus vivants mais qui
sont pas capables de nous donner la
maladie donc en moins d'être contagieux
par précaution ses on les donne jamais à
des personnes qui ont un système
immunitaire qui était faibli le vaccin
contre la kfw 19 lui dans une catégorie
à part
c'est un vaccin à arn dont qui utilisent
le matériel génétique du virus pour nous
immuniser matériel génétique c'est un
peu comme des plans d'ingénieurs qui
expliquait nos cellules comment
fabriquer un virus
ce qu'on fait avec ce vaccin c'est qu'on
utilise seulement une partie de ce plan
pour que nos cellules puissent ensuite
produire seulement un fragment une toute
petite partie du virus une seule partie
quant aux cellules vont produire ce
fragment le système immunitaire va
commencer à voir ses morceaux là à
paraître il reconnaîtra pas et ils vont
les attaquer c'est comme ça qu'on
apprend à notre système immunitaire à
reconnaître et à détruire le virus mais
en aucun cas ces fragments alors sont
suffisants pour nous donner la maladie
ou même à être contagieux
[Musique]
pour comprendre la réponse à cette
question il faut savoir qu'un vaccin va
pas nous donner une immunité immédiate
contre un virus
ça prend du temps pour que le système
immunitaire plus apprendre à développer
sa réponse est à bâtir cette immunité
dans le cas de lakovic 19 les études
cliniques ont montré que cette immunité
elle apparaissait douze jours après la
première dose du vaccin
donc si on entre en contact avec le
virus avant cette date
c'est quand même possible qu'on puisse
attraper la maladie et même la donner à
d'autres personnes
les études cliniques ont aussi montré
que l'efficacité du vaccin
quatorze jours après la première dose
est d'environ 92 %
donc ça c'est très efficace ça peut nous
protéger nous mais est ce qu'on peut
continuer de propager le virus dans
notre environnement après cette date
pour comprendre cela il faut savoir
qu'un vaccin va pas empêcher le virus
d'entrer à l'intérieur de notre corps
ils vont seulement permettre au système
immunitaire de le reconnaître rapidement
et s'en débarrasser
donc si quelqu'un qui ont reçu le vaccin
entre en contact avec le virus
est ce que cette personne ne voit quand
même transporter le virus avec elle pour
la donner à d'autres personnes qui ont
perçu une immunité l'immunisation ce
pour la kfw 19 les chercheurs ne sont
pas certains et ils sont en train de
travailler sur cette question
donc ça veut dire que tant qu'une
portion importante de la population nos
ports reçu le vaccin
il faut continuer de suivre les mesures
de distanciation sociale même si nous on
a été vaccinée